[Music]
in smelly leaked news submitted by hello
people but it's not evil oh I was
thinking we can't that's our thing about
dumping innocent a rotting durian fruit
prompted a gas leak scare and
evacuations of a college campus
Oh Jerian smells like gasoline yep
it smells like if you [ __ ] took a
dump in a pool of gasoline why do people
eat during its really sweet oh it's good
you know that [ __ ] fructose level
[ __ ] it's really high up there like has
a lot a lot of fat and sugar yeah thank
you like to do we were in Balaji Suzy
yeah he just it just doesn't smell it
you know what's weird like I don't
understand how people hate during but
they like jackfruit because it's the
same [ __ ] family a jackfruit smells
like [ __ ] - I don't smell jackfruit the
way I smell durian nobody says it is a
lot it's a lot more much at food isn't
even as sweet as a durian I feel like
it's worse here cuz they freeze it and
then they deliver it and then it's not
fresh but we had a fresh durian in
Malaysia and that should taste like
garlic
mango yeah oh yeah as a garlic I used to
yeah but it didn't smell bad though I
don't know
looks like you shouldn't need it looks
like an alien
yeah I don't know who found it first and
was like I want to eat this like
everything about it is leave me the [ __ ]
alone
did we look up durian deaths I think I
was a durian in my past life because
that shit's like [ __ ] five pounds and
it falls from the sky and it'll crack
people from the [ __ ] it and despite
be that you morbid bass though can we
look up how many people died from it oh
you didn't say that you said can we look
it up yeah look up some during death
yeah I'll see some during its oh hey
there's a cool bit I want to see this
video where the guy got hit by a truck
yeah watch it [ __ ] faces of dead
that's the one in traffic school right
the traffic school isn't the one where
you watched it in traffic school where
everyone dies no offence with that
that's like it was bad
Oh red asphalt that's the one I'm
thinking about that was [ __ ] weird
one that actually got me to use my
seatbelt oh yeah I did its job I think
that's what it's there for
cuz they literally showed a picture of a
kid flying out from the back and killing
his mom because his teeth cracked into
the back of his mom skull cuz even wear
a seatbelt and I was like that's like
scared straight [ __ ] right yep like a
Christian guy could easily let me tell
you about all the gay people that died
from having gay sex it's like oh right
we always had that [ __ ] at church where
some random gangster would come into a
suburban area and he goes you want to be
like me I'm like this is the wrong
neighborhood bro nobody seen an SML bit
right here dude that shit's like [ __ ]
like that all is so [ __ ] funny dude I
can't sign statistic numbers of how many
people die each year from during die for
me right they have there have been death
everyone's me that Jesus camp [ __ ]
remember that you can see the document
Jesus yeah that's crazy it was like
Hitler's youth yeah it's so crazy I have
a friend who her father was a very
prominent pastor like somewhere in the
south and so he sent her to a gay camp
you know but she said it was like
thought she was gay because she was
going to get reprogrammed so but she
said it was the dumbest [ __ ] thing on
earth because all them would just [ __ ]
each other yeah but I'm a cheerleader
one have you seen that where this girl
she's a cheerleader and then they sent
her to this camp like to convert her
from being gay or whatever but they they
all end up [ __ ] yeah yeah she said
they would either [ __ ] each other or
some of the kids who quote-unquote got
converted a lot of they got messed up in
there had something commit suicide like
it's just oh that's a bummer
[ __ ] yes sad for her she said it was
like a [ __ ] fest it was great that's
amazing that's sad I love them guys
though in those documentaries where
they're like they're like boy hello my
name is Craig I was gay but now I am
100% straight and I'm very happy my dude
there's a guy that was sad it's trying
to be crazy that we know who we all
could tell was [ __ ] flaming a [ __ ]
right and so you know we were all
drinking we're all going karaoke and
[ __ ] I was at a bro
you know gotta hide the fact that you're
gay we're know you're getting off
[ __ ] you talking about [ __ ]
straight right sounds like bro
it's all good we don't give a [ __ ] like
one of the homies he's gay too like you
get it was like hey hey this what he
said to me he goes he goes David I love
[ __ ]
same [ __ ] ever to me I got everybody on
YouTube
he was like I'm straight but then one
time he's telling me about how much he
loves [ __ ] and I was like oh you are
gay yeah who you don't want to just open
up like a [ __ ] Venus flytrap guys
don't talk like that we have no idea we
talk yeah that's right I never talk
about [ __ ] it smells like a mango or
something I'm a pervert but I never
taught that so yeah
even if we're talking about like oh yeah
like it's fun when she does his thing
whatever that we don't say like oh I
love [ __ ] oh yeah when I meant her
[ __ ] dude it's like yeah I love I love
[ __ ] big [ __ ] that's like this it's
like okay like a clear sign just the way
you said [ __ ] you guys like to grab the
[ __ ] like this yeah you guys never see
a sideways [ __ ] it's like that's just
what she's laying down oh it was
literally like that 40 old virgin moment
when you're talking about breasts oh
yeah what it sounded like like sad like
yikes and of course a year later this
guy is like bro gay like screaming it
out to the wall like you should have
just didn't repress it you could just
came out man
I just hate don't shame him he was in
closet for a reason pal you wasn't ready
he wasn't ready okay pal if he wasn't
ready he comes out when he feels like
yeah well you know what he did come out
he just didn't know he was out to come
yeah will you Ben it was like when Ricky
Martin came out and we're all like wait
he wasn't gay I didn't know okay I
didn't know you really didn't know no I
was I didn't want to know it's kind of
like for me it's like how are you gonna
hide it we went to the karaoke spot and
the first song you sang was a song for
Celine Dion it's like a pro that's like
when Lance Bass came out and he's like I
would like to announce that I'm gay it's
like somebody the back is wit know
yeah I mean everyone just blinked at it
like all right so not your name is Lance
Bass I let everybody together for this
[ __ ]
right I mean ghastly scared thing that
happened this happened in Australia and
so apparently someone left a rotting
durian fruit oh that's worse somewhere
hidden in the in the library Tobin his
brother oh that was a prank ha'la'tha
prank cuz durian foods are huge like
this how do you forget how do you forget
something like that because no one no
one goes to the library and go hey let's
study and crack open a [ __ ] dirty you
get a spoon and eat that like no one
does that [ __ ] it actually set off the
alarms thinking it was again yeah like a
person set it off or the smell so it
were like releases methane when it rots
is [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy so crazy
and so like 500 students and staff were
evacuated and 40 firefighters and
specialists recalled some oh my gosh
completely dirty and - isn't like a
fruit that Asian people don't know it
smells like you're not allowed to open
that [ __ ] up like in public transit you
can't have it you can't have it in
hotels like they will eventually banned
it's bad to ban substance
you'll get you'll get fined if you eat
it and put it in your fridge it stains
your fridge forever like the smell it
stains the French like a kimchi yeah
like everything else in that fridge it's
gonna taste like they're in his tears is
tear gas just durian I think that's what
it is doing holy cow
well you try to like tear gas asian
people is just nothing happens it's like
oh good moulding do you think see tofu
would smell even worse if it stays there
forever
I think Utah was really rotten if you if
you go to Taiwan you can have levels of
so I had all like three or four levels
of stinky tofu I had a taste why why
would you do such a thing because I've
learned to try things once and try to
get to make sure because even I tried it
three times it is I'm very the reason
why people like it and it was on the
tour thing right and his support I don't
know some wait were you with Timmy for
this no cuz Timmy was telling me that he
had
Tim to do here's something that he had
this bird that was still in the egg
course must try it no no chickens ever
I'm chill I was scared but it tastes
good it just tastes like I was shocked
so when it when you eat it like if you
can separate the taste from the thought
of it it just tastes pretty good big
salty then when you start tasting like
when you when you when you correlate the
crunch to the mini bones to the beak to
the to the feathers then the thought of
it is like good for me but then the
taste of it is not bad at all really you
also have hates your culture now because
Nicky you have to do it I don't remember
you have the Filipino [ __ ] microbials
on your dick I know tell me about it I
am you know it's all over my body Philip
it up anybody tell you that you just
have to get the ones that aren't the
heaven like Jess stated as long so a lot
of people [ __ ] up because they get the
the one that like the duck is fully
formed and that shit's all bad we had no
I got the one that was like super like
young so you could barely tell them I
should have [ __ ] wet feet I know both
feathers and [ __ ] baby be nope
cannot do I don't think I'll eat it
again really if it's there and I'm like
don't wanna be mad like mean I'll do it
I don't mind a mean when Nicky cooks
some like black beans she puts it in a
Tupperware container and puts it in the
fridge and you know [ __ ] two weeks
later when I'm like if I'm smelling
something in the kitchen it's always
black beans somewhere in the rotting
like when I open it it's like I could
die okay so no another black beans no
dude I swear black beans all black beans
won the war smells dude it smell yeah I
promise it is it like when you open it
just explodes out this yeah exactly
right it's like whatever it's doing it's
eating you through the [ __ ] plaster
why'd she leave me black beans around
the house tell me about it hey thank you
here ask it to camera you do this sorry
my lunch she just likes black beans a
lot she likes leftovers a lot but she in
theory but she doesn't really eat them
as much as I think that she could thank
you and they're real stain
I'm a real big boy now I don't yeah so I
think she should she's like she's like
you know we're at dinner and she's like
you could change anything about me would
you and I'm like no nothing ever so what
are your thoughts on where you are but
here I'm like oh god I can finally talk
okay yeah now she's the best she's the
best really
I'm very near Blackman and when she eats
obeah why just you to [ __ ] watch the
dish it's cement after an hour so the
trick to it is if you're not gonna wash
it just put water in it I wish that you
would just tell me she's eating oatmeal
so I could just do it then I know it's
done just soak it coz when it dries up
you do to save your [ __ ] marriage you
take that oatmeal you leave it next door
once you sleep advice with David so you
live with with your girlfriend right
absolutely that thank you the best
[ __ ] advice take that hit me back
then David so I cannot wait to watch you
and Mariel live together as of right now
I've I don't even live with her right
now and we're already going to that
toilet seat up issue you didn't like me
because you're spending more time over
there yeah so I'm like leaving that
Twitter step if she goes and I'm like
sleeping right she'll like wake me up
and she goes you forgot to put the
toilet seat [ __ ] worth it [ __ ] my
way she wakes you up
Wow what you want to push wants it up or
you want to know she wants me to put it
down she just she wants me to put the
seat down for her but not the cover not
because she's [ __ ] up that wakes you
up for that is [ __ ] up
like I'm like dozing off and then she
goes hey you left the toilet seat up
again and I'm like wow give her options
and leave it down and just pee in the
shower just be in the shower that's what
you do what the or the pee in the trash
dump it up do you think he does that you
just walk in the champion's job back I
just you know anymore
I peed in the same floor in the few
together
what [ __ ] wrong with you that was a
different time
those were a different time
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]